good morning believe nation today's
message is conceived believes and
achieve over to you Napoleon Hill
whatever the mind can conceive and
believe the mind can achieve
isn't that a profound statement you'll
notice that it says nothing about the
need for education but simply that's
whatever your mind can conceive and
believe your mind can achieve now if you
want evidence that the mind can achieve
whatever the mind can conceive without
the benefit of formal education you all
have to remember that Thomas a Edison
conceived the idea of becoming an
inventor and lived to become the world's
greatest scientists in the field of
invention there's only three months of
common school education so this is an
easy one for me because I'm all about
believe so I'm going to keep it short
today and get right to the question of
the day which is of the three things
conceive believe achieved which is the
hardest for you to get done I'm curious
leave it in the comments below and I'm
gonna join in the discussion thank you
so much for watching have a great day
continue to believe and I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
of an espresso I lost my wedding ring on
the jump it slough off as I jumped it I
know where it went
this is why I put on my right hand
because my right knuckles oh there it is
here it is okay back to the right hand
so it doesn't fall off my right knuckle
is fatter than my left good